so do you trust like Joel Osteen Osteen
trust him think he's like a man $1,000
he tell me he's not trusted no money
that guy's riches [ __ ] right I was like
what this was this he had a Kickstarter
well he is absolutely he's on TV he's a
he's a shyster they're all shysters just
that's what they are
yeah dress is real nice he talks about
Jesus and he gets people excited and
they give him them their money yeah they
give him their money that's what he
wants and he's got [ __ ] million he's
getting panties thrown at him didn't you
just get divorced Diddy do you get
divorced Google that he's probably
getting some serious God loving person
oh yeah jesus said Jesus blasphemous
tell me what job said I'll tell you what
job said baby get away yeah is that
blasphemous no it's like he's a leader
you know I mean that hears if it's long
as it's obvious like is a con bad if
it's real obvious to his followers he's
not a con mo to us it's like yeah yeah
but like you're talking about with the
cults when you're in it it's like I
don't think they can see it but like Jim
Baker like people have followed you back
yeah he's still around selling he is
people that scare the world's gonna end
he sells buckets of food but Tammy Faye
died right she does she died was a
long-suffering tarifa she died from die
coke diet coke did her in are you
serious that's the thing she drank too
much training all day
that stuff's addictive it is addicted
there's something there there they've
been studies and proven that there's
that whatever that artificial sweetener
is that they put in there yeah they it's
a it causes you yeah you know Jesus
Jesus and Jim beggars dick both things
are different it's Jim Baker was like a
perfect example though you're so [ __ ]
stupid you buy into that guy's [ __ ] yeah
I don't lose all of it I don't remember
I remember them I remember growing up
and watching like sketches on like MADtv
or whatever where they would be making
fun of yes yeah I want to remember
Robert Tilton
he's together his hair slicked back he's
another late-night guy he would talk in
tongues
you'd be on TV Oh Lourdes moving me to
speech he would speak in tongues this is
one thing he said I was listening to I
started [ __ ] crying laughs and he
said every time you write a check to me
Satan gets a black eye you know every
time you write a check to me Satan gets
a black eye that [ __ ] should totally be
legal if you're so stupid you like old
lease ain't nice might be and you pull
out your checkbook i smite you say new
or fiction you get a shiner there he is
look at him
he's gonna speak in tongues here I don't
remember this guy the devil I should
have said they're hilarious
he's Alerus now the devil a [ __ ] mr.
Satan gave me this mess Satan saliva
dental I should have said there was that
haze him he he speaks in like tongues
and when he is he really old look now
was that him there times such a cruel
[ __ ] even Robert Tilton went down with
all his money but he's still alive huh
probably but what do you whooping he's
old as far to know oh jesus that woody
look that's him I can't be the same not
him it is him what happened the 90s from
when that video boy all that whiskey and
[ __ ] and coke look at him he looks
doing coke for Jesus no no no we done we
wrapped jumps in a private jet 15
hookers in there waiting for him so he
touches down to shoot the hookers you
know too much stop it did a remix it
yeah it's a remix of him screaming
why aren't they remixed
anymore I know right remember I met that
guy came to UFC shut up right did he get
paid they made some money yeah he made
some money and Dana White brought him to
a UFC is this because he was gay right
and then men went to church and said he
wasn't gay anymore yeah he was ashamed
being gay it was very sad cuz he was
saying that you know he was ashamed of
being gay in that you know the church
was gonna they were gonna pray the gay
away it's one of them deals so that's
that to me makes me so sad it does it's
this there's nothing wrong with being
gay now and this this idea that you
could change someone from being gay so
[ __ ] stupid it's like just be gay be
gay you're gay it's alright it's okay
you just need better people around you
they tell you were okay they tell you
that they love ya yeah and just find
other gay people in you like oh you like
me we're good yeah you're good you're
fine you guys are gonna be fine yeah all
you need to do is move to Atlanta or
anywhere else for this delay LA and live
you know find a gay still be in the
closet out here too there's a lot of
people in the and I don't get it there's
people in show business that I know
they're in the closet man that goddamn
closet you have a new fan base and then
when you meet guys like Todd glass who
didn't have a closet it was so much
happier now he's like it's just a giant
burden relief talk relieved off my back
like yeah just be yourself man and you
know plus it's the stigma is so it's
it's bad for everybody it's bad for gay
people it's bad for straight people
because it's even bad for people or
homophobes because they don't realize
how many people are really gay right and
if they did they would probably be like
maybe this is normal yeah like it is
normal yes
yeah it's the beginning of times no
different than having blue eyes or black
hair or whatever the [ __ ] you are gay
yes
trust me my dogs gays [ __ ] really yeah
he licks my other dog's dick every time
my poor Marshall every time throwing him
under the bus maybe do it you don't know
well Johnny Cash my Mastiff when he'll
take a leak
Marshall come over and
lick his dick right after he takes a
leak [ __ ] away from his dick man
stop doing that dude so depressing gets
right up in there instantly